the Supreme Court agreed to decide
whether one of the men convicted of the
Washington DC area sniper attacks can
appeal his life sentence Lee Boyd Malvo
was just 17 when he accompanied John
Allen Muhammad on a killing spree that
left 10 people dead back in 2002 since
then sentencing guidelines for juveniles
have changed but for those behind bars
few options remain 48 hours
correspondent Erin Moriarty spoke to an
inmate in Missouri who claims he too was
given an excessive sentence when he was
young Erin joins us at the table good
morning good morning we're talking about
the sentencing of young people no this
story is not about the wrongfully
convicted
Patrick Flaherty did commit the crimes
for which he was convicted but he makes
the case that he received an unusually
long sentence and that he and others
just like him
deserve a second chance when I look at
my life and I think I'm 42 years old my
life is defined by a mistake I made 20
years ago and it doesn't matter what I
do that's the reality of the situation
Patrick Flaherty has spent nearly half
his life in prison
with an equally long stretch still ahead
of him you could spend another 20 years
here I could spend another 20 here I
could do another 20 doing the things
I've been doing you know the classes the
college degrees the charity projects and
I could spend another 20 here getting in
trouble then I would go for parole on
the same day on July 23rd 1999 at this
convenience store he waited until 3 a.m.
grabbed the BB gun that he says he
bought at Walmart covered his face and
then walked in it's a BB gun but it
looks like the real thing doesn't it yes
so I never had any intentions of hurting
anyone so I thought that that would
probably be the best thing for me to
utilize he got away with 128 dollars and
then two months later robbed a second
convenience store this time you got 89
dollars yes ma'am I mean you could have
had a minimum-wage job and made more
money than that yes ma'am flirty commit
two more robberies before he was finally
caught he was charged with four counts
of first degree armed robbery and
although the only weapon was that BB gun
he was also charged for carrying a
dangerous instrument how would you
describe Patrick celerity back then he's
a kid
Rickson del was clarity's attorney he
was a you know kind of a young man
without a lot of clues clarity took a
plea hoping for mercy instead the judge
gave him ten years for each of the
robberies and then she ordered the
sentences to run consecutively
you hear the word consecutive
consecutive consecutive and you start
thinking in your mind my god that's it's
40 years
flirty has to serve 85% of his sentence
before he's eligible for parole when
he's 57 years old when they took me back
to my cell they came in handcuffed me to
the bench and when I asked him you know
what are you doing they told me oh we're
putting you on mandatory suicide wash
because of your showing us
I think it's excessive retired st. Louis
Circuit Court judge Evelyn Baker
believes clarity got that sentence
because the robberies occurred in a
County where judges are elected and need
to take a tough stance on criminals
regardless of their age we have way too
many youngsters incarcerated throughout
this country judge Baker knows about the
harm of excessive sentencing in 1997 she
sentenced a teenager
Bobby Bostick to 241 years in prison
after he committed two armed robberies
around Christmas and one of the victims
was grazed by a bullet
I started regretting that sentence many
years later when the study started
coming out in terms of brain development
we've really should not be treating
children like adults because they're not
their brains are still farming but there
is no legal mechanism to undo that
sentence
Bostick remains in prison
as does Patrick Flaherty who has in the
past two decades earned an undergraduate
college degree and is working on his
master's and what we have here is a
temperature scale
he creates math books for the blind
after becoming certified in Braille
transcription
he has petitioned the Missouri governor
to take a new look at his case but he
fears the good he has done could not
outweigh the pain he caused I know in a
perfect world that uh I should probably
say that the emotional harm I caused my
victims is is what hurts me the most but
mr. Hart I cost my mom the judge who
sentenced Flaherty wouldn't discuss his
case with us but one of his victims a
store clerk did she says she doesn't
feel much sympathy for Flaherty because
she still remembers the terror of having
a gun pointed at her but then consider
this had Flaherty shot one of his
victims gone in with a real gun and shot
her and received a life sentence he'd
likely be out of prison earlier so it
doesn't make a lot of sense okay since
it's one of those things when you're a
kid they tell you let the punishment fit
the crime in both those cases it seems
excessive
so what options does flirty have he
seems to have redeemed himself yeah it
really only has one option and that's
going to the governor in a state like
Missouri a very conservative state and
the governor could commute the sentence
but what's the upside I mean that's a
really long odds against that because
what's the upside of supporting a
convicted criminal but the other point
here is how much money we are spending
in the state of Missouri to keep him in
for those 40 years there have been a
number of over a million dollars and
what's Bostick doing we see what
Flaherty is doing what's he doing he's
written poetry he's taking college
classes he - I would say is really on
the way of rehabilitating himself right
the judge is speaking out - am i
important at the grave of her I do -
very very interesting story and thank
you thank you